Now at the beginning of your career,
is it true that you had to face one of your biggest fears?
Actually take a look,
I'll show you what one of your biggest fears are.
(birds chirping)
Ah, yah, ew!
Oh, it's on your--
What?
Ew, ah, it's just!
Okay, okay, okay, yeah, just!
Oh! (screams loudly)
I know, I earned my paycheck that day.
Like that is crazy!
On my face!
Actually, we would love to reunite you
with your co-star if that's okay.
Oh, wait.
Rosie is here actually.
No.
Yes.
Rosie, would you please come on out?
I don't know how to react.
Oh, oh, okay, okay.
I did not know you were going to bring that.
I just have to say I did not know
this was going to happen.
This is like crazy.
Oh.
If I can open this.
There we go.
Yeah, oh my god.
Okay, so.
Okay.
Now I found out a few fun facts about Rosie.
She's single.
Okay.
She's eight years old.
Why am I holding it?
She loves Spider-Man.
Oh, (laughs) okay.
But hates "Itsy Bitsy Spider."
Okay, fair enough.
Doesn't like the song.
Irritated by it, gets her in a real cross mood.
And most people often typecast tarantulas to be dangerous.
Although, they do produce venom,
they're not really dangerous to humans.
(gasps) Oh, but I have to tell you something.
Hold on, now that she's moving, like how gentle it is.
Wait a minute.
Why am I feeling emotional about the tarantula?
It seems sweet.
You know that they can also jump like 20 feet?
Okay.
Did you know that?
If properly caffeinated.
Do you wanna hold her?
Oh, well I don't know.
I don't know.
Is it allowed?
No, I don't.
Are you gonna take her out?
Oh, I don't wanna hold her!
I don't know!
Here you go.
Okay, okay.
Do you wanna tell us about "Central Park,"
your new show?
"Central Park" is an animated musical comedy on Apple TV+.
You can catch it streaming.
It's about a family
that's raising their kids in Central Park.
I have to tell you, I think this is a show,
like it's so for me and my daughters, I'm obsessed.
We've been watching it.
It's great, right?
You know what we're watching right now?
You are calm around it.
(gasps) You're holding it.
Do you know what we're watching
right now, Ellie?
No, no, no, no.
We're watching "The Office."
Are you actually?
We are watching "The Office."
Is this therapy?
I feel like this has got, it's like equine.
Is that what it is?
Oh!
Yeah, equine therapy.
Except with spiders.
Oh, I don't like it, but I'm doing it.
I have to tell you, I feel cured of my fears.
You do?
I really do.
I mean, I do know that she is not in the wild,
nor full of venom.
So the fact that somehow at work it makes it okay.
Okay.
Whereas, in nature,
in the wild, I would never dare do this.
I see what you're saying, okay.
But it's Rosie.
Wait, hold on.
That sheet of paper said yes venom or no venom.
They have venom, but they're not dangerous
to human level of venom.
Okay, okay.
Just a little bit of venom, okay.
And no sudden movements, I just heard in my ear.
Okay.
I did not know that.
Well, thank you, Rosie.
Rosie, thank you.
Thank you, Rosie.
Ellie, do you think that we can
always just have fun on the show
and keep doing weird, cool things together?
Like the last time you were here,
we performed your school trip.
My school play.
Well, it was an at-home production of,
it was a Christmas play.
As long as we move slowly and gracefully,
we can do anything.
Yeah, I just got that memo.
We can do anything.
So we're gonna show your Christmas play
that we did a reading of on digital.
So you'll have to go to TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com
and our social channels to watch it.
But definitely watch new episodes of the fantastic show,
"Central Park," which by the way,
I mean, Kathryn Hahn, Josh Gad.
Just an extraordinary crew.
Tituss Burgess, Daveed Diggs, Leslie Odom, Jr.
It's a fantastic show.
The cast alone is crazy.
You have calmed me down.
By watching you, did I begin to feel
calmer around the tarantula.
You know what you did?
Life threw this tarantula at you and you just dealt with it,
and you did it very calmly.
So thank you for imparting that to me.
Ah, ah, oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god.
Uh oh, are you okay?
Okay.
Is it coming?
Do we need the wrangler?
Now I'm panicking.
Okay.
All right.
Shh.
Thank you, Ellie Kemper.
Thank you, thank you, Drew.
I went upside down and it wouldn't come off.
So I'm just gonna.
Okay.
Do we need the wrangler? Okay.
So new episodes of "Central Park"
are available Fridays on Apple TV+.
Is Rosie upset?
No, Rosie is just fine.
Oh, that's so great.
Ah, yay!
Oh, but not set in.
Thank you so much.
Not set in.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Ladies and gentlemen, Rosie!
Rosie, aw!
(audience clapping)
(upbeat music)